let's get rid of the bikinis from all
the television all right we'll just
cause no evening gowns either that is
serious objectification come on down to
Tompkins Square Park and look at my walk
the Miss America pageant if you haven't
heard they're that they're scrapping the
evening gown in the swimsuit competition
okay
so great idea my question to you for the
day what's the purpose of removing these
events like why take away the swimsuits
and someone explain the evening gowns to
me why remove key defining physical
beauty attributes from a beauty pageant
I think I understand where people are
coming from on this but I don't gretchen
carlson the chair formerly of the Fox
News leg chair
the chairwoman now the Miss America
Board of Directors announced the event
will no longer feature a swimsuit
portion and she said we will no longer
judge our candidates on their outward
physical appearance the competition will
be more inclusive to women of all shapes
and sizes they're no longer be judged no
longer swimsuits was actually to be said
it makes sense if you remember last
year's panel of judges I understand it
all and given last year's trending
LGBTQA AIP silent number s malfunctions
the wardrobe malfunctions were one for
the ages oh gosh inclusive your thing I
understand I understand that we don't
want a culture that continually presents
women is sex sex right right we all have
our solemn board I understand that
portion of it videos music videos if all
films if all radio programs if
everything in the entertainment industry
just portrays women is sex oh and there
was a period where we were turning that
way yes I understand that's a problem
and that's also by the way by brightwing
questions for decades they've been
wanting parental controls in wanting
rating systems because I don't want
their kids seeing strippers on
Billboard's or watching someone throw
someone over or gonna achieve I'm
watching Ricky Martin throw someone
belly down and plow them on the versace
show that can be in primetime and FX and
then recruits and you're so close-minded
but let's get rid of the swimsuit
competition America that's where you
draw the line really and what's crazy to
me is listen there is it I think we're
in a day and age we all agree it's it's
tough it's tough tomorrow I'm concerned
when I ever hit yeah what the internet
things just pop up but in regards to
Miss America I don't think
anyone here's under the false assumption
that this has ever been anything other
than scantily clad women being judged
based on their looks who doesn't want to
be empowered learn leadership skills and
pay for college and be able to show the
world who you are as a person from the
inside of your soul she added
yes trip club a we tune in for the
Cornell scholarships the entire point of
Miss America a beauty pageant is to look
at attractive ladies and be inspired by
attractive ladies being attractive
nobody watches a pageant for your
beautiful Souls kindly show us your
breasts so that's the report there in
about covered well covered dish I've
seen a couple sarong pasties or anything
I mean come on I mean here's one thing
to me that once you get past even you
get past the swimsuit the idea of
objectifying women and if you buy into
all of this that's a problem with a
beauty pageant they're now getting rid
of the evening gown portion as well my
Miss America Organization will instead
ask them to express their personal style
and clothes they feel confident and so
Miss America is no more going to have a
bikini competition they've done it was
the evening gown competition and it will
no longer effectively be called Miss
America really it's just a one-way
mirror in a TJ Maxx dressing room that's
what we're talking about this is and
this is why people find this so absurd
again because you're removing the core
element of the essence of Miss America
is physical beauty no people shouldn't
in in life engine will be solely judged
on their physical attribute right of
course not it's nice for you to be
insolent a job interview it's nice no it
is in the job interview is I'm gonna
rage you on a scale to Tannen how good
you look good sorry we've got a long
list of applicants let's speed the
process huh no longer judging physical
appearance because because personality
was the reason people been tuning in
relate this back to education and Wow
we are continuing to try to strive to
[Music]
I think it's great that Americans are
able to choose one or the other we live
in a land that you can choose same-sex
marriage or opposite marriage I
personally believe that us Americans are
unable to do so because some people out
there in our nation don't have maps and
I believe that our education like such
as in South Africa and the Iraq
everywhere like such as and I think we
better just skip to the portion here on
Fox News tomorrow and this is not going
well
swimsuit I figure lasted effort so in
Miss America was first created in 1921
it was actually what they called a
bathing beauty review huh it's more
accurate I didn't even know that was it
really a thing but you know what that
that was just bathing suits that's a
nice way of saying do not the active
bathing no no I don't I don't think so I
don't think they had people rooming and
I was only later and I think 1930 1935
that the talent port talent we used the
term loosely we've hadded
in 1944 they switched from giving out
furs and movie contracts as prizes to
awarding scholars
I'm that big picture deal how about a
degree to brown Oh son of a [ __ ] that's
how it started it was available to you
and they gave out fur and movie
contracts has mostly been run by women
historically by the way yeah this isn't
a bunch of Patriarca store sitting out
on how can we get the ladies to undress
Lenore Esteban Oh evening for example
the longest director was Leonora s
slaughter from 1941 to 1967 yeah so by
ditching the bathing suit review portion
of the bathing suit review competition
they're eliminating the entire the core
element of the competition here's thing
I can understand for example why
feminists would think it's wrong maybe
to demand that WNBA players for exempt
playing negligees right because they
aren't paid to wear negligees they're
paid to play basketball if you want to
watch Husker will and play basketball
about thirds of speed of college males
with weaves littering the floor the
delegatee is a thing it's right up your
alley
okay would it be wrong for example to
make WNBA players posed in Playboy yes
because that's not what they're paid to
do
performance based now if one of them
wants to pose for Sports Illustrated
swimsuit I have no problem with that
they won't sell but I can understand
what you would be upset when something
is performance-based to force them to
wear something a scantily clad let's go
with bodybuilding it's like bodybuilding
versus strong man okay we don't have any
ill-conceived notions that bodybuilders
are actually strong or judge anything
other than looking a certain way many
body blows couldn't give you a run
around the block vanity is the goal is
the goal that's like telling them to put
on a loose-fitting muumuu and go into
the competition exactly this is really
work and by the way Muslim will be out
lifted by college football players watch
the bio there's no I'm not saying you're
not a strong mister anavar now strong
men though they have to perform that's
it that's performance base the guy who
lifts the most wins so you don't have to
you don't have to oil yourself up in a
thong for strongmen you just have to
perform bodybuilding is different
because you were entirely judged on the
aesthetics so a beauty pageant the
performance here is the bikini
arnold complaining also now i have to
oil up my body and go out in the song
and do things to joe either yes you do
if you want another if you want another
atlas trophy think about the future
breaks Joe Weider women women are
prettier than men yes that's easy that's
why men have to perform that's why men
typically only watch women's beach
volleyball at the Olympics and beauty
pageants okay if we want to watch the
best football watch men play football or
watch the best hockey would watch men
play hockey if we want to watch the best
basketball we're going to watch the NBA
if we want to watch the best people who
are pretty and are attractive and excite
us we're going to watch women that's it
we don't care we don't care if you can
twirl a baton tell us you're bilingual
it's put on the swimsuit sweetheart
that's why we're tuning into this by the
way a lot of women tune into this as
well you just think you can do the
amount of power that women have this is
another thing we want men want to see
women naked okay regardless of where you
line up more like I've talked about
waiting and toes marry with my wife so
right now I've offended Christians
because I think we're speaking too
bluntly and then we'll offend a
secularist because we have moral values
but sex is something normal men are
attracted women men want to see women
naked okay we want to see you naked
well okay
second a bikini a bikini is a way for
men to see women and for women to see
other woman and see the beauty of the
feminine form without it being a
violation of the FCC that's my most
wonderful art includes the female form
it is absolutely beautiful a naked woman
is a beautiful thing and if you want to
talk about toxic masculinity shaming men
for being attracted to naked women is
wrong now pornography is a whole other
problem we've had Gary Wilson on the
show we've talked about the dangers the
pitfalls of pornography and creating
that neuro pathway in your brain I'm not
supporting that at all what I am saying
is a problem is shaming men for wanting
to see women in bikinis that's okay you
know what no bikinis men like seeing
women naked but we also like seeing
women in nightgowns we like we like when
women we like when women dress up when
we put on makeup like we try we like
when you try mm-hmm well we don't I
don't want to wear I don't want to wear
a dressing gown I refer you back to
point naked does it make it does it it's
a crowd-pleaser
it's just like the Boy Scouts I want to
move it because it's offensive but
that's the core element is the Boy
Scouts right it's the Boy Scouts I don't
feel comfortable it's boys but there's
the Girl Scouts let's just do away with
all the scouts and make it just
something else but that was why it was
created it's a beauty pageant let's just
do away with the beauty component can we
make it a spelling bee oh no because you
said opposite marriage hordes of
feminists cigarette butt I find so funny
supports strong them in the sex you can
watch documentaries right now on Netflix
yes that the sex worker is independent
and you have no right to judge so that's
a good point one thing I don't get it
all is how anyone any what is that this
is the issue why it's so silly can feel
confined this degrading feel happy about
its ban well simultaneously supporting a
[ __ ] walk or wearing a [ __ ] hat how do
you justify that one let's get rid of
the bikinis from all the television all
right we'll just go to no evening gowns
either that is serious objectification
go on down to Tompkins Square Park and
look at them look at them while I walk
I did I walk like this video you can
subscribe or click like subscribe or hit
the notification bell which is right
next to the subscription button because
descriptions don't mean anything anymore
or you can watch The Late neck late
night show every single day at lotta was
quite a dot-com slash smoke let me get
this handout smog all these other shows
and you can subscribe and watch it every
day so we can keep doing this because
youtube doesn't want to pay us lateral
clutter that comes flush MO clip
subscribe notification bell someone call
9-1-1